I once again cannot believe that we have to
do this again.
But Donald Trump still doesn't understand
how this virus or viruses in general spread.
He doesn't understand contagion.
He doesn't understand communicable communicable
disease.
I don't know if you've heard this, but the
White House is increasingly overrun with corona
virus infections.
Trump is reportedly furious.
People are having to quarantine one of Mike
Pence, his staffers, his press secretary,
Katie Miller.
She happens to be the wife of Trump adviser
Stephen Miller, a sick, sick guy.
More nepotism anywhere you look.
You look under a rock.
You look behind a curtain at the White House.
It's nepotism.
She has tested positive for Corona virus.
One of Trump's valets.
These are Navy people who are essentially
person very close personal assistant to the
president.
They handle his meals and that type of thing.
One of Trump's valets has tested positive
for Corona virus.
Evancho, Trump's assistant, has the Corona
virus.
Why?
You know, she she even has any role in what's
going on at the White House is another question.
But she does and her assistant has tested
positive.
Dr. Anthony Foushee is now in a modified self-quarantine,
along with Dr. Redfield of the CDC, because
they were exposed to people who tested positive.
And Donald Trump doesn't get it.
How could Katie Miller have the virus?
She was previously tested and she was negative.
She was tested again and she was negative.
Now, all of a sudden, she tests positive.
How does that work?
It makes no sense to Donald Trump.
Look at this tragic video.
This is maybe the dumbest thing that Donald
Trump has said in his presidency.
Maybe.
I mean, it's up there.
It's in the top ten, certainly.
Take a look.
Pitroda virus is now the second stop for the
Westway.
Well, I don't know much about it.
Does anybody want to talk about it?
It's.
She's a wonderful young woman, Katie.
She tested very good for a long period of
time.
And then all of a sudden today she tested
positive.
She hasn't come into contact with me.
Spend some time with the vise president.
It's, I believe, the press person.
Right.
Say press person.
So she tested positive out of the blue.
She tested very good for a long period of
time.
Then all of a sudden, she tested positive
today, I guess for some reason, she tested
positive out of the blue.
That's how it works.
At some point, everyone on earth was negative
for coronavirus at some point out of the blue,
I guess, to use Trump's phrase.
People started testing positive who previously
would have tested negative if they had been
given a test.
Guys, he still doesn't understand it.
He still doesn't get it.
He's visibly confused by an even more catastrophic
is that Trump then uses this as a justification
to say tests aren't that important.
Someone can test negative and then test positive
tests don't really matter that much.
That's Trump's conclusion from all of this.
Take a look.
This is why the whole concept of tests aren't
necessarily great.
The tests are perfect, but something can happen
between a test where it's good and then something
happens.
And all of a sudden she was tested very recently
and tested negative.
And then today, I guess for some reason, she
tested positive.
So Mike knows about it.
And Mike has done what he has to do.
Something can happen between tests.
Yeah, it's called catching the virus from
someone else.
That's how a virus works.
He actually says people test negative and
then they test positive.
This is why I'm saying testing isn't that
important.
No, that's why testing is important.
And huge amounts of testing are necessary.
Levels of testing that we are nowhere close
to.
There is no worse person to be dealing with
this crisis.
There is no worse or more incompetent administration
to have in power during a global pandemic
than this administration.
We're trying to scale up testing.
We're trying to evaluate reopening strategies.
We're trying to explore the connection between,
you know, vitamin D and the virus, heat and
humidity and the vibe, all this stuff.
Trump wonders aloud about bleach injections
and still doesn't understand how a virus works.
When he says, I don't get it.
She was negative, then she's positive.
It's almost like he sees Corona virus as a
hereditary thing.
Listen.
She tested for having type a blood for years.
All of a sudden she tests for type B blood.
It's really weird.
How could that change?
Right.
That's not what this is.
She was born Asian and now she tested black.
That's really weird.
I thought people's race, they know this is
a virus.
This is how it works.
This is how people catch.
Shit.
And this is at this point.
I think it was Bill Marr who said on his Friday
program, lethal incompetence, lethal incompetence.
That's what we're dealing with.
And my biggest fear and I you know, when we
talk about 2020, I try to keep it to just
the facts.
Biden's better on climate.
Biden's better on judges.
Biden's better on taxes.
Biden's better on health care.
Biden's better on capital.
Right.
Just we've got it.
We've got an option.
These are the two options we've got to choose.
Everybody's got to vote.
But I do fear that the guy is going to get
reelected.
I know that the polls are looking pretty good
for Biden.
This guy has figured out a way.
You know, he lost the popular vote by 3 million
and 70000 votes in three states, combined
with who knows how many other X factors that
we've talked about, suppression, Russia, etc.,
etc..
Kobe coming out and talking about Hillary
unnecessarily a second time.
Any one of those things could pushed him over
but 70000 votes in three states.
He won the electoral vote.
I fear that once again he'll get lucky and
there will be a decline in the virus just
before wave to end it all time right out in
early October with people saying, Hey, you
know what?
We got past it, even though it took longer,
even though more people died.
He got us past it and they're going to go
out and vote for him.
And I'm worried we're gonna have another four
years of this.
And it is lethal incompetence.
As Bill Marr said, let's work really hard
to make sure that doesn't happen, particularly
as you see what's going on with federal and
Supreme Court judges.
This is urgent.
And when it happens over four years and the
country is still here, we might feel like
it's not that bad.
No, it's very bad.
And the death toll is going to be much higher
in the United States than it needed to be.
The economy is going to suffer much worse
and far longer than it needed to suffer thanks
to this.
And we've got to all keep our eye on the ball
and not forget that in five and a half months
we have an opportunity to change who is in
charge.
We can change who will be in charge for wave
two and possibly wave three of this.
And we've got
to do that.